uh hey let's bring in a real live
action hero uh into the proceedings here
on inside there
i can only hear what goes on presented
by kia
uh kevin hart star of die hard
uh is uh is joining us kevin how are you
man
i'm good man i'm good ernie i'm loving
the uh
the weight adjustment that you guys had
to make with that table because of check
shack and chuck that's a that's a a
pretty fat ass
check and that's what that is right well
uh
kevin i can see that uh you know jumanji
must ain't do that well you got the
little ass diamonds on
you couldn't come out of this pandemic
with a better suit option
i'm so sick of you and chucking these
awful suits y'all been wearing looking
like two beacons
hey everybody everybody can't go and get
these suits off a mannequin like you can
i'm sorry i'm sorry hey what's up what's
on the prayer menu today chuck you make
me sick
and who told you
you don't think if you don't take off
that baby gap shirt before you
come up here talking to us crazy why
don't you give tea
wine
you know he got tiger woods disease yeah
he wears those medium shirts to make it
like look like he's muscular wearing a
little tight shirt get a shirt to fit
you won't be so muscular
medium
kevin do you spend your night watching
hoop tonight man uh i did man
i actually enjoyed the game i heard what
kenny said earlier
it didn't uh it didn't look like i
thought it was gonna look i thought that
would be thrown off
by the fact that there wasn't a crowd
there but looking at the game from home
i enjoyed it i followed it um you know i
didn't find myself
wandering at all i was still locked into
it happy that the game of basketball is
back happy to see my guys
back on the court doing what they love
and providing some entertainment through
this tough time
yeah through the tough time kevin but as
a fan let's say if they said
you know as a fan you can go in the
bubble and watch games
yeah could you do that could you go in
there for a month and a half and say i'm
as a fan you get your front row seat and
you're going to be in there as you
always are could you do that i'm going
i'm going i'm i'm there a thousand
percent i
listen i'm at a point now where i
understand the seriousness
uh of course behind kovid and
and all that it's done but you know i i
am uh
i'm also in a place where i'm just kind
of ready to get back
to some type of life and going down to a
place where they've quarantined would
have taken the precautions
if i had to do the same thing and i
passed whatever precautions there were
and i could watch the game of basketball
i would do it i'll be there every day
enjoying it until we get out of this
you know kevin as a great stand-up
comedian
and when you playing in front of a great
crowd
and playing in front of a miserable
crowd that's kind of the way this thing
is with the nba players now
how would you get your juice if you were
these nba players when you're playing
like when the crowd's hot it's easy but
if you're playing against a bad crowd
how you get yourself going
well you know what man i think this is
where the word team comes in play like
this is where you depend on your
teammates you depend on those other
people that are on the floor with you
and on the bench because ultimately
you're motivating one another
so it's your job to get out there every
night do the job at hand
but make sure that you guys stay focused
because like you said that crowd
that crowd acts as another as another
man
or you know individual that crowd gets
you back into a game
when you're falling out of it and you're
falling apart so i can definitely
understand
not having a crowd of the impact that
that could have on you but
this is where the stars got to be bigger
stars and the role players got to be
better role players
um you know but some people are used to
that i remember when kenny kenny you
remember that time when you were in the
dunk contest
and it was the first time i noticed your
needs was like that and
it was the first time that i noticed
because your shorts were small are you
in your house because you seem like you
ain't got no furniture in there there's
a
little big echo in there you ain't got
no furniture in the house
that's why this movie the new movie is
coming out yo all right bro you going
broke
i'm not in my house i'm over a friend's
home okay i don't trust y'all enough
to let y'all see my background i refuse
to do this interview
in my home i don't trust shaq i don't
trust shaq further than i can see him i
never had
[Applause]
i was awesome i recognized you right off
the bat but man i had to do a double
take on john travolta
yeah john travolta man uh very lucky to
get john travolta
in this project he uh he wanted to do it
we were we were excited to have him he
came on
uh destroyed the part man i can say that
it was an honor working with him but he
he made the project that much more
better
so uh die hard is uh is something that
i i didn't expect it to be but with his
involvement it exceeded so many
expectations so we got
extremely lucky who haven't you worked
with that you're going to work with man
because i've seen
you know when you were doing the uh you
your
your reality about your life and you had
different people coming in and different
who haven't you worked with that you
want to work with right now i've yet to
work with denzel
i've yet to work denzel washington man
um
you know me and will smith still haven't
done a movie we right now we're trying
to figure it out
i think we're getting closer um but
denzel
denzel is definitely one that i hope
that i get the the privilege of working
with
before it's all said and done for you
know me and my career
uh he's a he's an icon he's a legend and
you know the man just doesn't miss on
screen so i'm gonna go denzel first
kevin uh i'm glad you're smiling when
you answer some of the questions because
besides that we probably wouldn't be
able to see you
uh can you let us know this is a movie
or a tv show because i'm kind of
i'm i'm you know i'm kind of yeah i'm
ordering right now you wait i don't know
well shaq listen i can understand your
confusion about what this is because it
shows in your eyebrows
i don't know uh
obviously you're just in between stages
the pandemic has affected us all
differently
you know what you should realize about
this
it's a it's a short series you know it's
a it's a minister
okay you did that to yourself man
i tell you man it's gonna be a short
series
it's a mini series oh
it got worse it makes it worse
[Applause]
yeah that's all right you don't have to
answer the questions
not going to be a big thing just kind of
making a piece of content
that's available on quibby uh i love it
it's something that
uh heartbeat productions my production
company
and laugh out loud my my network we put
this together we packaged it
produced it developed it quit became one
as partners
gave us a platform to put it on so you
know this is about the next stages in uh
in our creative career i'm very lucky to
have the people that work alongside me
and
this is the business of making movies
making tv making content
and we're doing a good job of it so i'm
excited i'm excited for people to see
apparently you got the social media
buzzing here with your appearance here
on inside the nba let's see what's uh
let's see what's out there oh
hey dylan that's not very nice dylan but
it's true dylan
just take to reach one end of the desk
[Laughter]
uh longtime friend of the program thank
you
so much for hanging out man i appreciate
you get your diamonds up before you
start talking crazy to us
i'll be honest with y'all though you
don't realize the impact that people
have
uh in your lives man on that tv screen
i've honestly missed you guys i'm glad
to have you back
uh it's it's it's been a long time but
you guys do an amazing job and i think
the people are definitely happy to have
you guys back so
i know i'm a long time friend of mine
show but genuinely i appreciate the jobs
you guys do
hey thank you man i love you man and get
some drapes
shirt okay
look at chuck's pocket hey hey you got
enough money to get a shirt to fit man
stop squeezing that's medium it's called
shoulders why don't you stop dressing
like a finger that's upside down
hey man get off there get off the set
have i told you lately how much i love
doing this show oh my god i love this
like kevin hart man back with the best